thanks I'm sure haven't really targeting
that I have been a fan of Matt's work
he's one of my intellectual heroes for a
long time since the origins of virtue he
is the supreme synthesis of our age I
think for getting so many different
fields together and the rational
optimist i think is his best work yet
and and i love this you know the idea of
ideas having sex is a great concept
before we explored i just want to ask
are there any videos why do you briefly
explain to us what the concept of idea
is having sex you know the big thing
with my book is that innovation comes
from exchange from from people swapping
things and ideas is that its equivalent
to sex so I came up with this and at one
point we're going to call the book you
know when ideas have sex and things like
that but we took a vote on that Jerry
didn't we're meeting and it was thought
a little too facetious and there have
been places in the world where I've gone
to give talks and the organizers have
said great really want to hear about
your book book can we ask you one thing
don't use that phrase manages that's in
my shop much more than we realize
innovation experimentation cultural
advance comes from people swapping well
people swapping things as well as ideas
and I can come back to this because
actually I think there's an issue that
people people think that what I mean is
just people getting together in a bar
underground New York and and talking to
each other I don't really mean that
actually I mean technology I mean the
fact that every technology we possess
has has ideas that occurred to different
people in different times of different
places in it and that actually what
embodies that you know where we're say
where ideas have sex is in technologies
and the people driving this
intellectuals and politicians like to
think that scientists like to think
they're driving the process of
innovation of course politicians like it
claimed credit for but in your book you
talk
you give the credit elsewhere yeah I
mean I'm persuaded that this is all a
much more bottom up process than we all
think that because of Nobel prizes and
the patent system and the newspapers we
give qui too much credit to individuals
for innovations and that all of them
actually are simply standing on the
shoulders of lots of other people and
that most innovation happens by
perspiration on inspiration in other
words it's tinkering people live doing
technologies rather than geniuses in
ivory towers and one of my problems is
getting this idea across in academia
they don't like it they think it's all
about geniuses and they think what I
mean is that the more people share that
the more people there are because it's
also a demographic phenomenon that I'm
talking about you know the more people
are talking to each other the more
innovation you're gonna is going to
happen the more people rather more
chance there is of one of them being a
genius that's that that's the common
meme out there that everybody thinks
that you mean by this and I don't mean
that at all I actually you know it's
funny you know that that the outlier
theory I coolant and academics just
can't leave that one alone because there
are the outliers I out loads exactly
sorry I'm sorry but you also give her
her but you also give a lot of credit to
the reviled traders and businessmen who
you know who tend to get blamed for
exploiting people and and and for infant
being social parasites we're in other
words you see them as a source these
traitors going back of course to the you
know you know back to the times of the
Stone Age and people were trading tools
and things right yeah I mean I do think
that the invention of trade was the key
ingredient that kicked off the process
that led to civilization and everything
we had huge brains before that
Neanderthals had huge brains and you
know we had love and insight and
jealousy and you know all these sort of
weird thing
empathy I'm sure we had all that kind of
stuff but until we had trade you just
couldn't get cumulative accelerating
technological evolution and set suit it
you know if you go back and look what
we're doing it where is the great
flowerings of invention and discovery
there in trading nations there in 17th
century hollander and nascent italy or
ancient greece or abbasid Arabia or Tang
China you know so Fibonacci for example
is one of my favorite examples the guy
who brought numerals you know the Indian
numeral system that we all use they
thought it was Arabians because he got
it from the Arabians but actually the
Arabians has got it from the Indians hmm
he brought that to Europe and why well
because his dad was a Genoese peas and
trader living in North Africa talking to
Arabs and you know so so so just stop
knocking traders they're great people in
the book you've got this unit just
wonderful array of evidence from you
know from from Tierra del Fuego from you
know isolated islands that and and
throughout the world and throughout
history has there been a new evidence
since you know since you've done the
book for those of us who know it's in
the book yeah I was very excited by a
couple of things that came out one was a
really nice model based study of what
happened in Africa after about a hundred
and sixty thousand years ago between
that in about sixty thousand years ago
because you get because you get these
sudden flowerings of really
sophisticated technology in Africa as
long as a hundred and sixty thousand
years ago to place called pinnacle point
in South Africa etc you get you get
suddenly an elaboration of tools that
you just didn't see before that and then
it fades away again then it happens
again then it comes you know it comes
and goes and then finally it kind of
breaks out around 60,000 years ago
around the world and never stops
expanding so what's happening in Africa
before that and these guys at University
College London have basically said that
the best explanation is demographic that
what you're essentially seeing is that
because these people living on the coast
and we're living off shellfish they were
able to generate really quite large
populations quite dense populations and
so it's a demographic phenomenon the
more people there are the more chance
you've got the specialized skills to
start developing these tools and then
what happens is there's climate change
or something and they disappear I mean
that you know the population density
collapses again and and then the
technology disappears as well and along
the same lines as a very nice study
right two guys at UCLA of Pacific
fishing tackle from before Western
continent and basically the the the
bigger the island the most sophisticated
the tech the fishing tackle which is
this demographic there's more ideas have
but also if you control for size of
island the proximity to other islands
and the amount of trading contact gives
you more sophisticated so two isolated
islands have more simple technologies so
in other words what's driving innovation
is not how clever you are in the room
it's how many other rooms you're in
contact with and the tender Tasmanian is
on which I do have in the book is just
this spectacular example of this that
when tasmania became isolated 10,000
years ago not only did it not share in
the technologies that came along in
australia after that because it was out
of contact with them so the boomerang
for example never reached Tasmania but
it actually regrets and it actually gave
up technology the idea is that 4,000
people was just two smaller collective
brain to sustain the specialist fields
you need in the exchange patterns you
need to to keep keep these technologies
alone so I think there's a there's a
really interesting sort of thesis in
here we
and I can't get I mr. economists like it
but they're not that interested in the
archaeology the archaeologists on the
whole just aren't interested they want
to talk about and culture and things
they don't really want to talk about it
it can anything economic because it
sounds too dirty and trade and the
biologists are courageous because they
weren't wrong about jeans you know sir
so it it's an idea I want to keep
hammering away and the contrast you had
was that Tierra del Fuego which was also
an island about the same size and and
and but it was more closely connected it
was it was an arrow straight to the
mainland right the Magellan straight is
quite narrow and there was trading
contact across it the whole time whereas
the Bass Strait was no trading contact
oh sorry for those 10,000 years that
Tasmania was an island and so that the
yog an and other Indians on on Tierra
del Fuego they got things like the bow
and arrow and all sorts of other
technology they got them from South
America so it's a good example of how
they had a continent-sized collective
brain to call on and we've got and they
had and the Tasmanians didn't and of
course the implication of all this is
that we've now got a planet-sized
collective brain thanks to the internet
and that must be accelerating the rate
of innovation because an idea in
Shanghai can have it sex with an idea in
San Francisco mm-hmm in 10 seconds
mm-hmm you know where as a hundred years
ago it took six weeks or something yeah
and and I just sort of feel in my bones
that that that much it was sure there
are people who are left out and assure
the Internet is going to get balkanized
into different areas and so on but but
nonetheless that the possibility for
that the number of people involved in
this collective brain is bigger than
ever isn't he and that must I must be
going to accelerate the rate of
innovation the counter-argument to that
which I sometimes tie with is that
that's fine for areas where innovation
can help like communication recently the
last 50 years communication is
incredible advances but transport hasn't
really you know we all thought in the
50s the transport would go surging air
and we'd all be having personal
gyrocopters and routine i knows travel
by now and it didn't happen so transport
hit diminishing returns hit a brick wall
so maybe all we're doing is accelerating
the idea sex with in communication and
biotechnology and a few other fields
which will get to the point where
communication cost so little that it's
just irrelevant to everyday life it's
sort of it's free like the air we
breathe mm-hmm and at that point all
your budget is going on things that
we're ideas can't have sex like
government and you know looking after
the elderly and things like this where
you can't see the productivity
improvement certainly so that I call
this the high hanging fruit argument
that you know we may perhaps all this
enables us to do all the internet
enables to do is to plot below how you
prove quicker mm-hmm and we're left with
the areas of of it's a version of power
malls disease mm-hmm you're more
educated than me Johnson you that isn't
the idea which farmall had this notion
that well basically that that some
things are less easy to see cost
reductions in yeah because they're more
labor intensive you're sort of left with
the ones that are tough to innovate well
Matt Welch is here tonight admitted it
made the argument with Nick that of
course in the transport in these areas
are where the government is taken over
that's where there's no progress that's
where we feel so stifled and it's and I
guess the question is can ideas have sex
in enough to overcome that obstacle to
somehow shove the government aside to
work around it I mean you kind of work
around the postal service that was a
monopoly that just SAT there now for
some we just don't we don't
anymore yeah yeah yeah that's a good
example but now okay two hours ago I was
standing at JFK having loner in London
and there was a line you know how it is
and there were empty desks all the way
along and there was sort of five guys
dealing with 700 people from all over
the world and it took about an hour and
10 minutes to get through immigration
yeah and not only was the no incentive
for anyone behind those desks to feed
back the information that has I mean
walmart treats you like that is dead and
yet there was not only there was the no
feedback but there was no way of you
know if I had gone up to when I got to
the front if I'd said to them very nice
guy behind the desk who start like buzz
but if I'd said why does it take an hour
and a half and couldn't you get a few
more people you know on there you know
there's several flights arriving I'd be
in whatever that island is are you bread
spread eagle to go naked so you know
instead of feedback mechanisms are not
there in the public sector right but
you've argued in the book I think when
you said that the danger that the sum of
this process will stop the government
that there are processes that can stop
this sort of exchange of ideas but your
hope you say in the book is that there
will be that even if it's even if one
place manages to stop at like you know
the way China closed itself in at one
point that they're always be some other
place this is base a cause for optimism
but it's also just a tiny bit of a worry
because um you know when China screwed
up and you know China was roaring ahead
of the rest of
in terms of Technology and living
standards and everything in about what
about a thousand years ago and basically
what happened was the Ming Emperor's
came along and shut the health system
done it was bureaucracy that shut it
down you know Abe and trade not a great
start they told merchants that they had
to send the mandarins an inventory of
their stocks every month you know and
that kind of thing and they weren't like
that but never get permission to trader
how to get permission to go from one
town to another and they had to offer
contraceptives I think too yeah yeah
that's it so you know China drops the
ball mm-hmm and Europe picks it up and
Europe's advantage at that point is that
it's it's you can't unify Europe
Napoleon had a go Hitler had to go
Charles the fifth letter go it's
impossible to many peninsulas too many
mountain ranges the way you can China
all right China's because of the rivers
that run right through the middle it's
quite easy to unify China and so Europe
never had one government till now and
and as a consequence it always had
different jurisdiction this was David
Humes theory anything about why Europe
was overtaking China it had different
jurisdictions and if you look at the
careers of almost any innovator in
Europe people I Guttenberg or or others
and that they they move no they move
they say I don't like the way this rule
is treating me I'm going to go and live
in someone else's think so that was
terribly important for your now why
Europe haven't got his act together
before I don't know it's just too cold
and wet or something but but Renaissance
Italy kept the flame alive when Arabia
drop the ball now ready to drop the ball
not because of bureaucracy so much is
because of superstition in other words
it you know it burnt all the books and
it turned its back on opening quote but
it had kept the flame of knowledge alive
you know so so so far we've been lucky
someone's kept this this Cadillac see in
higher
eggs were this habit of exchanging ideas
and and being free and open and trading
someone's kept it going somewhere and at
the moment you know there's no risk of
it dying out the Chinese or the Indians
or the Americans or someone is going to
keep the game but you know just suppose
we did a China we did a sort of Ming
Empire to the world this time hmm yeah
suppose we said right we're going to
regulate all trade on the grounds that
we want to make it fair okay green or
make a ring ring whatever exactly and of
course that's what you see and that's
what you're going to hear a lot of a
trio yeah couple months time it is the
notion that trade is bad for the
environment which is clearly not the
case but you know it at this point do we
not have a plan B do we not have a
reserve planet to keep it going you know
is it is there a worry that the
somewhere on this there isn't somewhere
in this world that can keep a habit
going I'm not very worried about that
but just a tiny bit of me might be do
you have any thoughts bet I know what's
been the reaction to it to your
promotion of the this open exchange in
trade and and I mean what are the
hurdles you see to get in this idea
embrace for but because intellectuals
are some of the people who really don't
like this who seem to be most against
this idea of yeah I've unregulated my
books gone down like a lead balloon in
academia and then they get hung up on
sort of particular things so so for
example I make the argument that if the
habit of exchange is unique to human
beings and I'm very careful i qualified
and I say well what I mean is exchanged
between strangers you know exchange
between kin sure that some of that goes
on in in ant colonies or in mated pairs
of birds or whatever and i say i'm not
talking about reciprocity i'm not
talking about one baboon scratches one
balloons back and the other scratches
doing the mines back
I'm talking about exchanging different
things you know I've got fish you've got
meat hmm I've got fruit you've got bread
or whatever it might be I've got money
you've got beer and and as Adam Smith
famously said no man ever saw a dog make
fair and deliberate exchange of a bone
with another dog and when I say that I
mean I gave a lecture at University
College London a couple of months ago
and and all these professors they put up
their hand one by one and one said well
there are some ant colonies where there
is a low degree of relatedness and I was
about to ask you better and then there
was another one who said Neanderthals
did exchange objects move long distances
so I said really a neat and he said yup
definitely so acidic have you got a
paper on that because I've got lists
these papers saying that they didn't
live in train well I heard it a seminar
but 20 years ago can you give man no but
it definitely happened you know yeah in
a sense my phrase is wrong it's not
ideas I mean ideas do have sex and you
know your ideas having the Texas my
ideas at the moment but it the exchange
is of object the exchange that leads to
it is of objects you know I give you
money you give me beer you know that's
what leads to ideas having say it's not
the fact that we are I mean sure there's
a linguistic exchange too but I think
more important and everyone very in
academia runs very interested in the
evolution of language and then the
degree to which we exchange ideas
through language but I'm saying there's
another thing going on which is that
that um I make what I'm good at and you
make what you're good at and and we
embody lots of different ideas in the
things we make so we end up with you
know a pencil which was then agreed
family said nobody on the planet
how'd it make you know there isn't a
single human being who knows how to make
a pencil because the man who runs the
pencil company only knows how to run a
company in the man who cuts down trees
in Oregon doesn't know hurt and mine
graphite in Sri Lanka and so on you know
so so so this this notion that the focus
on material technology isn't of interest
or academia on the whole and it's where
my interest normally I'd like to thank
markedly I very much a little team